what's going on guys this is rob and and
you guys have questions and i have
answers so so before we get into that
one thing i want to say that I think
really needs to be said is you're all
support here has been unbelievable given
the the family things that I have going
on in this video I don't want to focus
too much on that I think that I like to
keep you know I like you guys to know
what's going on in my life but I want to
make sure that that this channel doesn't
go to like a darker place you know where
all i do is go on about my family issues
and so on you know I don't want you guys
to see all that stuff you know I'd
rather just keep this as a comic book
review channel so so in the interest of
that what I'm going to do in this video
is I'm going to answer a lot of the
questions you guys have none that sort
of like a big deep QA or anything but
you guys have asked a few things you
guys have a few concerns that you guys
are wondering about in terms of of
what's going on somebody just follow me
on Twitter Carl Jansen awesome but I
Thank You Carl you're awesome but yeah
so so one of the questions you guys have
is why are the age of Ultron video so
short why are they so much shorter than
the other videos that I've done the
reason why is because what you guys are
going to find as you guys you know watch
these reviews and you guys go out and
buy comics and stuff like that is you're
going to learn that Marvel has become
more organized and more concise and
condensed in terms of their Marvel like
crossover big story events it used to be
back in like the 90s with the age of
Ultron one of the things that people
will tell you comin book fans will tell
you is there's no organized no real
organized method for reading age of
Ultron or age of age of apocalypse it's
just kind of like hey guys here's all
the comics for Age of Apocalypse like
freedom and try to sort them out if you
can but that's pretty much it it's not
like it is now you know with age of
Ultron where you have age of Ultron
plant one or even with civil war where
you have civil war part 1 and then you
have a whole bunch of times and then you
have civil war part 2 and you have a
whole bunch of times and you can go back
and you can read like you know civil war
the Daily Bugle and it'll give you like
all the comics that you need to read in
order to keep everything in check you
know it wasn't like that back in the 90s
and so what you'd find is that with a
lot of the stories mother would just
cram a whole bunch of stuff in there
that's how it was with like infinity got
on the for example like you know when we
were doing our review of the Infinity
Gauntlet you
has noticed that the videos were 20
minutes 30 minutes and the reason why is
because what Marvel did is they took a
whole bunch of information and they
packed it into the comics but what would
happen with Infinity Gauntlet in one
comic in this day and age if it was
released would happen over two or three
comics just because people's attention
spans are shorter people like getting
you know information quick and fast and
it can also allow Marvel to create more
dialogue give the writers a chance to be
a little more I guess free in terms of
what it is they do and so on and so
forth but the fact is is that now you
know when model death stories when they
do you know all new x-men when they do
access when they do the original sin
event you know at all I kind of get set
age of Ultron the stories are more
condensed than work impact and so
because of that when we do our reviews
there just s condensed and compact oh
the other thing that you guys want to
know is what happened in civil war part
6 all right so the video had to be taken
down I intended to edit it and re-upload
it but then I screwed it up so some of
what part 6 doesn't exist anymore I'm
sorry guys um you didn't really miss a
whole lot in civil war part 6 you had
Captain America's forces who were more
or less like let's get together let's go
do this you know let's go fight Iron Man
you had like you know the Punisher I
think that killed some bad guys or
whatever but for the most part all it
was was like this story build up where
they arrived at at Rikers Island and
then into the negative zone and then it
was like you know the confrontation
between Iron Man and Captain America's
forces and civil war part 7 so it was it
wasn't it wasn't like a major thing you
didn't miss a whole bunch of stuff so so
you guys are fun for the most part um
one of the other questions that I get is
is what happened like why is it in age
of Ultron that the death of Hank pen
cause like such a terrible future like
Hank Pym xong important Hank them didn't
matter okay we'll get to this and civil
grams are in an age of Ultron part 8
tomorrow but I'll tell you guys right
now for the sake of argument what
happened the way the Tony Stark explains
it to a brain is that because Hank Pym
was killed presumably they thought he
was killed by Scrolls that the Avengers
broke up shortly after and because the
Avengers broke up when the crease
squirrel war took place in the normal
mainstream Marvel continuity the crease
World War didn't actually come to the
planet Earth
instead the Avengers were able to hold
it off and that's how they were able to
eventually get Captain Marvel and so on
and so forth but the fact remains that
and this alternate reality when Hank Pym
was dead The Avengers had broken up and
because they'd broken up the crease
World War actually came to the planet
Earth but will actually learn other
stuff later on like will learn to a
degree won't really go too much in depth
about her but we'll talk about like
Morgan la Fey and Morgana lafay is a
really really cool character she's a
cool villain she's not like a huge
villain you know she's not on par with
like Ultron or apocalypse or Magneto or
anything like that she was largely a
largely equivalent of Doctor Doom Spider
Woman the defenders I think for a little
while but she's not a huge huge villain
but in the age of Ultron her role is
much bigger than it ever was in the
mainstream Marvel Universe so um so that
that's it that's really you know what
was going on with hanging pan that's why
his death was so significant because it
led to the death of the or to the end of
the Avengers so anyway um that's pretty
much it for this video if you guys have
with the questions let me know and post
them in the comments section and I'll do
a Q&A or something like that and try to
see if I can get those questions
answered for you because I know you guys
will have a lot of other questions about
stuff and marvel comics in general
besides um besides this you know besides
you know age of Ultron and Hank Pam and
and you know some of war part 6 and so
on and so forth um but for those of you
guys who are interested in and here's
what here's a deal we'll go ahead and
talk about this now since since I've got
this thing going um there's some stuff
that I know you guys want to know
alright for example like thor ragnarok
alright that movies coming out Ragnarok
was not like a one-time villain in thor
ragnarok is an amalgamation he's a
representation of something in thor now
we'll get into that when we talk about
Thor but he is he's like onslaught
fourth or more or less um when it comes
to like a lot of the other movies that
are coming out captain marvel of course
nothing that's going to be about carol
danvers if you guys have noticed and i
don't think any of you have if you guys
have noticed of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we've seen Carol Danvers I just
don't know if you guys spotted her or
not I'm curious to see if any of you
guys have opposed to comment let me know
where you saw her at um there's some
other stuff too i'm really excited about
black panther that'll be a really cool
movie i think it's really cool to see
his character finally getting some some
notoriety and getting some screen time
dr. strange as far as i understand
models still up in the air about who
they're going to actually catch for the
role I think the rumor is Benedict
Cumberbatch but I don't know that's
actually true or not
um but yeah so so either way you know
the model Cinematic Universe is cranking
up really really good and the stuff
they're doing is really really cool so
I'm really excited to see what happens
but anyway um yeah I'll catch you guys
later peace